foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan bad hair day Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists what's
up frizzy
look I know my hair is Frizzy you don't
have to tell me in the comments okay you
know that means you're just gonna
exactly exactly well those delicious
voices you hear with us we got malabama
in the studio hi everybody we got TK
Coleman here it's the most wonderful
time of the year coming up today on this
free public minimal episode we're joined
by a board certified clinical
psychologist and we're talking to a
listener about heartbreak and letting go
of your ex plus we have an outstanding
lightning round segment a live stream
question and a listener tip for you you
can check out the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 383 where we answer
four times the questions and we dive
deep into several simple living segments
that private podcast episode is out
right now at patreon.com the minimalists
your support keeps our podcast and
YouTube Channel 100 advertisement free
because say it with me y'all
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers if you have a question for our
show give us a call 406-219
7839 or email a voice memo for that
beautiful voice memo quality right from
your phone just send it to podcast at
the minimalists.com our first question
today is from Harper hi my name is
Harper and I had a question about
um letting go of your ex
um when you have done that
intellectually and you're trying to do
it emotionally or you mostly have but
physically like in your body uh like
your body hasn't let go um I'll still
have almost like trauma dreams about my
ex like uh she still has
apparently some power over me or my
nervous system uh still thinks so anyway
like I won't think about her for weeks
or months at a time but then
um we'll have uh dreams about this
person and
have to wake up and actively think about
letting go
what do you do when your body sometimes
physically won't let go of a person
joining us in the studio right now to
help us answer this question and several
other questions is Dr Courtney Warren
she's the author of this new book
letting go of your ex it's a book about
healing the pain of a breakup and uh
also overcoming love addiction Dr Warren
thanks so much for being here yeah my
pleasure thanks for having me now we
want to get into a pretty difficult
topic to discuss here with Harper
specifically he's talking about
heartbreak and the inability to sort of
let go it sounds to me like there's some
healing that needs to happen here and
before we dive into the question itself
I thought your book was really
instructive for his question in
particular I'm reading here from page 89
of letting go of your ex where you talk
about the faulty beliefs about your ex
and I'm obviously not going to read the
whole section here but the first faulty
belief is my ex is the best hmm X is the
best they complete me they're this
magical human because when you're with
them it feels amazing
if anyone out there has ever been in
love you know that feeling I'm talking
about it's euphoric it's a natural high
you meet them you're with them and you
feel wonderful and because of that you
will create a whole belief system based
essentially in lies because you're gonna
idealize them over almost any other
human
and what happens is that ideal version
of them is sort of this 2D cut out this
nostalgic cutout you look at them in the
rear view and of course they're perfect
which is actually the next faulty belief
my ex is perfect and perfect for me
perfect for me because I've put them on
this pedestal I feel amazing when I'm
with them I think about them all the
time I crave them I want to be around
them I'm planning for our next
Rendezvous it's this wonderful magical
fantasy experience but as long as we're
together yeah
I am going to be happy yes I am going to
have meaning I am going to be important
my life is going to work out and so they
must be perfect they are the perfect
specimen I have found the perfect
specimen for me and that pivots
perfectly into the faulty belief number
three my ex's choices reflect my value
oh and that's such a tough one after you
break up because at some level as we put
them on a pedestal and we idealize them
and we feel amazing we think that their
comments thoughts opinions are valid are
true are somehow reflective of you and
who you are and what you should be and
what should matter to you and so if they
don't like something you're wearing
something you say something you like
your way of being in the world it feels
like a personal attack it feels like
somehow you are diminished
and I guess maybe the opposite might be
true where you look at let's say you
break up with someone and you look at
their partner and you're like oh I'm way
better looking I'm not partner like I
saw someone uh some girl tweet she was
like oh uh you know it doesn't matter
that my boyfriend broke up with me
um his his new girlfriend is way uglier
than me and then someone retweeted and
was like sounds like he learned a
valuable lesson about looks
that's a good point though because if
you take if you like make a list of all
the things your ex criticizes you for
someone else might love you for those
very same qualities right absolutely and
you know what else is really fascinating
per your example sometimes you look at
your own friends people you love and
people they are dating and they are
giddy and gushing and oh this person's
amazing and you're looking at their mate
going are you sure like 10 what you're
seeing here like they might be fine but
and you can see it you see their
deception we seize deception
self-deception in other people
way more easily than we see it on
ourselves and that's really a lot of the
Journey of understanding who you are
over the course of Life yeah and we
don't always understand the value that
we bring perfectly either Derek sivers
was talking about this with like a music
experiment where a number of different
artists had to cite what's your best
song and when they put a list of their
best songs and then they talk to the
fans the fans didn't even like the
artist's selection for best work but the
fans were like oh this changed my life
about things that the artists themselves
didn't think were that good and so
sometimes we think oh I'm valued in this
relationship because of this attribute
I'm proud of about myself and the other
person's like no I don't care about that
like the looks I don't care about that I
care about your funny so while you're
busy gloating over the fact that my new
significant other is worse looking than
you I'm rejoicing in the fact that
they're funny because that's what I
always valued yeah I'm gonna get into a
couple more faulty beliefs here this one
I think is one of the most dangerous
because we believe it to be true it's
faulty belief number four my ex will
change or I can change them and so there
is a line in our first book uh
minimalism live a meaningful life that
Ryan and I wrote way back in 2011 you
can't change the people around you but
you can change the people around you
quite often what we do is someone's in
our life and I will love you
conditionally if you just change these
seven things about yourself oh you'd be
the perfect partner right and of course
if I were to somehow convince you
manipulate you persuade you to change
six of those I'm gonna roast over the
seven or even worse I get you to change
all seven what do they say a man
convinced against his will is of the
same opinion still that you don't
actually change them by changing the
sort of surface ornaments in a way and
so can you explain banned a bit on this
idea of I'm going to change you
so often when you're going through a
breakup there's this churning phase
there's this phase where you're not sure
if you should stay or go you really love
someone profoundly you've built a life
with them but it's not working right and
so you're on the brink of leaving and
after you actually break up there is
this questioning and self-doubt of well
maybe I can change them I can change
their mind I can get them back I can fix
that I can change myself or I can make
them love me again I can make them want
me again and it becomes this hyper
fixation
on a fantasy again on something that
isn't really real because you can't
change someone else the only person you
can change is looking right back at you
in the mirror that's right that's it
we'll do one more false belief here
faulty belief it's the sixth one here I
need my X to be complete now in order
for me to be complete I need that person
to complete me and this is Insidious
before we start a recording we were
talking about how most great pop songs
love songs are about this sort of
misunderstanding of love you complete me
I need you I'm lost without you and all
this great music while it sounds really
good and where in fact we're going to
listen to some really good music later
during the added value segment on the
podcast
but it's this belief that oh having you
having this in this idealized version of
us is going to make me complete and
quite often what happens is we lose
ourselves in that and I think this ties
back closely to Harper's question here
when he called in he said I'm having
these trauma dreams and it's almost as
though part of that is like oh I'm
feeling this incompleteness and perhaps
that partner is going to not just Heal
Me Help Me heal
but they're also going to complete me
it's going to make my life not just
better but complete
I absolutely hear the trauma in the
nightmares that Harper was talking about
and I think so much of the recovery
after a break of of letting go of an ex
after a bad breakup is
re-finding yourself your identity your
meaning your values given that this
person who you probably built a life
with at some level is no longer there
now what what do you bring to the table
who are you what do you care about and
it's really common to have lingering
symptoms after a breakup much like he
has where you intellectually know it's
over I know it's over we're broken up
I've radically tried to accept this but
now I still have symptoms I still feel
lost I still cry I still get triggered
when I walk by that coffee shop we used
to go to or I see a picture or our
mutual friend says oh I saw so and so
your ex last week
and so they still have some hook in you
and it feels very frustrating for a lot
of people because they intellectually
don't want it you'll even hear people
say
I don't even like them anymore I don't
even know why I'm thinking about them
anymore why do I care
and so part of that Journey for him
which it sounds like he's doing a pretty
good job of is continuing on your own
path to creating your best life today
and that means adding in new social
supports it means cutting off contact
with your ex as much as you can he's
having a little contact in his own mind
much to his own dismay through those
dreams and there are ways that we can
strategically help him with that as
psychologists or as mental health
professionals
but so much of it is refining your own
value refinding your own voice
remembering that this breakup doesn't
break you it doesn't actually have
anything to do with your value if
someone else doesn't want to be with you
anymore you have exactly the same value
as a single person than you did when you
were with your ex
and that's something a lot of people
forget
okay you know um there's a story of two
guys sit in a coffee shop this beautiful
woman walks in and one of the guy says
man she's gorgeous I'm gonna make my
move I'm gonna ask her if I can buy her
a cup of coffee she sees him coming and
she says I'm not interested he returns
to his seat and his buddy says how did
it go he says Ah she wasn't that
beautiful anyway and then his friend
says let me guess she magically became
ugly the moment she rejected you
Letting Go does not mean ceasing to be
attracted to your beautiful qualities
Letting Go does not mean oh you were
funny and now I'm convinced that you're
no longer funny people continue to be
the same talented Charming beautiful
inspiring people they always were even
when we part ways and letting go is
really about saying I'm committed to
creating my future in a way that doesn't
involve the two of us playing the same
roles that defined our past it doesn't
mean that someone has power over you if
you still find them attractive in
certain ways so if you look at an old
picture and you say wow she's still
beautiful if you go to sleep at night
and you have a dream about her that
doesn't mean she has power over you that
means she's compelling she's inspiring
she's beautiful and you're a reasonable
person for ever being attracted to her
in the first place and letting go means
I can receive that I can allow space for
that and I can still remain committed to
doing what is healthy for me in spite of
the discomfort of having those feelings
sometimes it sounds to me like what
you're talking about here with Letting
Go part of it is the the healing process
as well it's healing is sort of a
gateway to letting go but of course we
can't do healing right I remember when
Ryan broke his back a few years ago he
had to sit up in the hospital for a
while and then in bed for a while and he
couldn't do the healing you got into a
car accident a few years ago or last
year actually it's not even been a year
yeah yeah wow and you had to heal from
that
and there wasn't something that you
could really do to heal now you can
strengthen yourself after the fact but
the healing involves actually letting go
of the doing and so quite often what I
would say to someone like Harper is
letting go of this person just requires
more healing to take place and the only
way you can heal is putting yourself in
the right environment for a protracted
period of time it sounds like you're
already getting there Ryan what time is
it you know what time it is it's time
for the lightning round where we answer
your questions from Tick Tock yes indeed
now you can follow the minimalists on
Tick Tock Instagram Facebook and Twitter
at the minimalist now during the
lightning round we each have 60 seconds
to answer your questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes over it
the minimalists.com podcast so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like looks like we
have a question here from Sylvia I think
people who need you to communicate your
expectations don't know what they're
doing in a relationship and will
ultimately disappoint you how can you
make yourself happy instead of expecting
your partner to
well that's a good turn let's start 60
seconds on the clock for Ryan and allow
him to dissect this
oh man here's my pithy answer no one can
make you happy they can only enhance the
joy that exists inside you amen and you
know I had an x one time that I broke up
with and I constantly looked back as oh
I would have been happier if I would
have had them in my life I I should have
done better you know I was completed
back then and man I should certainly
feel incomplete now but what I realized
was that incompleteness is not her fault
it's my fault and why would I ever give
that power to someone to have that
domain over me to make me happy or not
so don't give that power to someone else
be complete on your own and then anyone
else that enters your life
be great if they could enhance it we
were talking with Courtney on the
private podcast Ryan exactly about what
you're saying but the thing that's
fascinating is all these love songs that
sort of talk about or movies you
complete me right but the truth is you
incomplete but it's not even you that
incompletes me it's my need of you to
complete me that paradoxically
incompletes me and so it's beautiful I
love what you said here no one can make
you happy they can only enhance the joy
that exists inside you so you can't
pursue Joy through someone else through
a relationship but you can find someone
who amplifies that Joy that's inside you
we have 60 seconds on the clock for my
good friend TK Coleman
communication is not a substitute for
chemistry no matter who you are and how
much the other person loves you there
will always be some things that need to
be told and you're setting yourself up
for a life of continual disappointment
and resentment if you demand telepathic
Knowledge from your partner with that
being said however
no matter how much you communicate you
will not enjoy that relationship unless
you are with someone that is committed
to learning about you making themselves
a student of your heart and delighting
in the ways that they can surprise you
in the ways that they can make you
excited without you having to spell it
out and prescribe it for them so
communication matters but only when it's
based on a foundation of real energetic
compatibility there's something in you
that creates a spark in me there's
something in me that creates a spark in
you and once we have a dance that's more
fundamental than the words then we can
bring in the words and the words can
amplify what we have but without that
dance without that spark without that
fire
our words won't get us there I love what
TK is saying here Ryan he seems to be
describing in our last book love people
use things we talk about how every
relationship especially Intimate
Relationships but any relationship
really is a three-legged table or it's
like a tripod that tripod that camera's
on over there
it requires all three legs and if you
take one leg away from that tripod what
happens it tips over right and the three
legs for any relationship compatibility
which you talked about chemistry which
is important and love in chemistry you
know right away you have some sort of
chemistry with someone like the three of
us have a particular chemistry on this
podcast or when you have sexual
attraction to someone there is a
particular energy or chemistry you feel
there and that's easy to notice it's
really difficult to sustain in fact on
the private podcast I do want to talk
about some ways to sustain it and also
talk about how we can take cheating off
the table in a relationship as well and
so we'll talk about that but the other
two legs love in some respects that is
the easiest and the most difficult we
mistake love we say attachment is love
we say clinging is love we say needing
is love we say conditions are love but
of course that isn't love to love
someone is to see them for the who they
are without trying to change them
manipulate them convince them persuade
made them right and if you can do that
it's a type of Acceptance in a way and
so now you have two legs but the third
leg which we often forsake and we try to
make work is compatibility and if we're
not compatible with someone it doesn't
matter how much I love you it doesn't
matter how much chemistry we have
together oh the energy is just there but
if we are not compatible and I've been
in relationships and most of my exes at
this point it wasn't because we didn't
have chemistry we did it wasn't because
we didn't have love we did it's because
we simply weren't compatible and what
happens is when you realize that you
cling tighter to the relationship and
when you cling tight to that
relationship what happens you get
dragged in the direction of chemistry
and of Love so-called love but that
isn't love at all real love has a
willingness to let go if there isn't a
compatibility there one other note on
that sometimes you're compatible for a
season and that compatibility ends
because your values change your beliefs
change their values change their beliefs
change their preferences change and
that's okay just because you were
compatible a year ago or 10 years ago
doesn't mean you're going to be
compatible today or tomorrow it's crazy
how when you have two of those things
how hard it is to let go because you're
like 66 percent there and to let go of
that 66 percent it's uh yeah it's
difficult well back in school 66 was a D
minus that's what you'll get out of that
you'll get a D minus relationship it's
not enough to fail
but it's almost there how dare you share
my high school grades
for Sean
love is not Tethered to expectations
Ryan and I often talk about how
standards are greater than expectations
and expectation means hey I expect you
to do this I expect you to do this I
expect you to complete me I expect you
to make this relationship better I
expect you to do these things in this
sequence
and then we will be happy here are my
expectations well that's never going to
make you happy because no one is ever
going to fulfill all your expectations
and quite often you're going to have
expectations that don't align with their
expectations but what can you have you
can have high standards standards for
yourself here's how I behave in the
relationship someone yells at me I'm not
going to yell back at you that's my
standard I can't expect you not to yell
at me but I can have the standard where
I'm not going to yell back I'm not going
to retaliate and so love is not Tethered
to your expectations but it's easier to
see when you have high standards
we're gonna check in with our patreon
live stream here in a moment but first
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists It's the final
Sunday Symposium Well for now at least
it's been a really fun experiment we did
four sold out events last year Sunday
Symposium in Los Angeles small groups
the smallest events that we've done in
many many years 200 seats at Dynasty
typewriter it's the theater uh there in
downtown Los Angeles Sunday
symposium.com is where you can find
tickets and I think there are maybe a
dozen or so tickets left at this point
by the time this episode comes out so
Sunday symposium.com
what do you all enjoy about these events
oh I love the intimacy of it man it's
funny you said uh the smaller crowd that
we haven't done in a while I mean 200
people man
I mean like I remember when it was two
let alone 200. but I like those intimate
events because I feel like there's just
more connection that we can bring and
that we can have with one another yeah
yeah what about you TK yeah there's just
the real magic that happens uh when you
bring people together in the same
physical space you know
um it can be easy to dehumanize
ourselves by treating the essence of our
Humanity as if it's primarily mental or
spiritual hey I can get everything that
I need from Ryan over the Internet or
over the phone but we are embodied
beings our bodies matter our physical
presence matter our ability to shake a
hand to make eye contact you know
um those sorts of things matter and and
there's a certain kind of synergy that
is created when you have the energy of
bodies present in a room United under a
common interest to connect and that's
what I love about it it's the things
that we can't predict the things that we
can't promise because they're things
that we co-create together when we come
together we've got a nice little
surprise at this one as well it is March
26th Sunday symposium.com just a few
tickets left over there let's check back
in with the patreon live stream Alabama
what do you got for us here's a question
from Melanie I recently broke off a
three-year relationship in our last year
together he took leave from his job to
work on his mental health but after
eight months of trying to support him I
could no longer continue being his
therapist and mother instead of his
partner I truly care for him and I want
him to heal but how long do you wait
before you move on
yeah uh 17 months two weeks three days
four hours 16 minutes 23 seconds and
that's the problem with prescriptions
here right it's like it may actually
take that long in fact they they did
this survey how long it takes to move on
from an ex and on average it's somewhere
around 17 months and that's why I was
joking with that number but that doesn't
mean that oh I would simply wait 17
months and that's how I can move on but
also while you're while you're mired in
their discontent
it is also making you discontent yeah
because that discontentment is
contagious and what we don't realize is
that you spend enough time around the
joyous person it seems to rub off on you
but if you spend enough time around a
miserable person it will often rub off
on you even if you are predisposed to
Joy and pleasantries over a long enough
timeline yeah this is actually you know
it becomes this discontentment becomes a
prison and it's true in fact that like
if I were to put Ryan in a prison an
actual prison here in California he's
going to
over a period of time maybe 17 months
he's going to start acting the way the
other prisoners act in that prison right
we so we become imprisoned by our
relationships we become imprisoned by
our own expectations of the other person
yes you want your you want this man to
to heal
and um
totally respect that yeah but you can't
force healing onto someone either you
can as Ryan has illuminated you can
support them but sometimes your level of
support
you might confuse support with what
you're actually doing which can be
well it can be
incentivizing them yeah to continue and
so you become an enabler of this
behavior that you're actually hoping
that they can heal from yeah they start
to get like addicted to the the sympathy
that you're giving them man um yeah it's
possible to love and support someone
from a distance so it doesn't mean that
you have to stop talking to them all
together
um you know I think about that that
cliche of uh Time Heals all wounds
and I'll tell you I got divorced at 22.
and I remember like the first week or
two weeks
um that we were split up
I had a friend tell me
uh who went through the divorce process
he said hey man I know how you feel
right now it feels like
the world is coming down you look at
other people and you ask yourself how
could they be happy and you feel like
you're never going to be happy again he
said but I promise you he's like in one
year
you're gonna feel better
and he was exactly right that is how I
felt I felt depressed I see people
smiling what are they so happy about the
world's terrible you know like I had
this this um angst and this this stress
and anxiety in me and I'll tell you at
about the one year mark I started to it
started to fade a little bit and I wish
I would have really taken that in when
he told me that because when he told me
that I'm like oh okay yeah right dude
like okay I yeah I'm depressed but this
is the worst advice I've ever been given
because it doesn't mean anything to me
but a year later I'm really uh I really
did start feeling better so I wish I
would have would have taken that to
heart so you know as far as like when to
move on you're gonna know when it's time
to move on there is no prescription for
it there's no exact time frame of when
to move on because you can't sit down
with a pro and con list yeah here are
the seven reasons I should stay in the
relationship and here are the seven that
I should leave right because the truth
is that some of these things are
intangible or they're so they way so
much more I tried to do this with place
where do I want to live right and for me
Southern California there's a whole lot
to recommend not living in Southern
California the high taxes the traffic I
can name a bunch of things right but I
so outweigh the weather but I also weigh
the way that it makes me feel exactly
like when you're ready to move on your
heart will tell you it's time to move on
TK you want a last word here for Melanie
yeah I think the best kinds of friends
and partners are the ones who are
capable of keeping up with your own
Evolution you're doing what's healthy
for you and you're a life organically
intersex with all of the people who are
compatible with you if you have to say
well in order to keep you around in my
life I got to be unhealthy you know I
gotta be depressed well that's not only
bad for you in a self-interested sense
but it's also bad for the other person
as well this is why I love your decision
to stop playing the role of therapists I
commend you for that because
that's not just a drain on you but if
you're not a therapist then that means
you're playing a role in his life that
you're not qualified to play and you're
doing harm to both of you or if you are
a therapist and you are qualified to
play that role but you really don't want
to be there then that means you're going
to be doing this resentfully so it not
only drains you but it also puts him in
a position where he needs to be
elsewhere and he's spending his time
getting help from someone who resents
him for the help or who simply isn't
qualified to provide it so I commend you
for that and what I would say is moving
on doesn't have to mean hey look I'm
just gonna find someone else to date and
call it quits forever for us and close
out that possibility moving on can
simply mean I'm going to make sure I
treat my health as something that
doesn't have as a prerequisite you being
completely whole I'm going to be healthy
now and if you can meet up with me
sometime in the future
then so be it but in the meantime I'm
not going to treat your health as a
prerequisite for mine
that's an astute point because
quite often the best way to ruin a
relationship is to expect the other
person to play every role in your life I
need you to be my lover my partner my
therapist my mommy my business partner
and all of a sudden you're have all of
these different expectations and it
ruins the relationship why because it
sucks the chemistry out of it right and
it makes you less likely to even be
compatible with that person so Melanie
it is not your duty to fix anyone else
especially your partner you can support
that person you can be there as they
heal but it's not your duty to be there
and if you do decide to move on past
this relationship that also doesn't mean
this relationship was a failure the
failure would be staying in a
relationship that is no longer serving
you and by the way if that
relationship's no longer serving you
it's difficult for you to be of service
to the relationship um Alabama what else
you got for us here's the minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners hi
this is Donna Jensen from Virginia Beach
one way I found to get rid of my paper
crafting supplies was to donate them to
preschools elementary schools and middle
and high school art departments due to
limited budgets teachers must buy most
of their own supplies for arts and
crafts so they were thrilled to receive
my vintage supplies some schools may
even write you a receipt for a
charitable contribution so you can at
least lower your taxes a bit even though
you won't realize the money that you put
into the supplies to begin with
all right that's our minimal episode for
today we'll see you on patreon for the
full two hour maximal edition of episode
383 which includes answers to a bunch
more questions like what's the
difference between clinging to someone
versus having a Sentimental attachment
to them and how do I deal with
resentment in my relationship plus we
got a million more questions for Dr
Warren and the minimalist also this week
we have a private minimalist home tour
we take a peek inside our talented
filmmaker Jordan no Moore's home we're
calling it clutter no more
very good we also have an outstanding
added value segment for you some talk
aboutables and much much much more of
less if you want to hear all that check
out the minimalist private podcast at
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
access to all of our podcast archives
all the way back to episode zero zero
one and if you're still on the fence
here's a testimonial from one of our
lovely patreon supporters Cheryl says I
am so grateful that I found the
minimalist private podcast I never
thought of myself as a hoarder but
I guess I am my home is a small
Warehouse full of Broken Dreams
I've also come to realize that my
obsession with collecting things comes
from the need for self-actualization
thanks to you I now know
that I can let go
I added that a little bit to make it a
little bit shorter but what a beautiful
comment from Cheryl thank you so much
for your support understanding that you
can let go I think it starts here and
that understanding is so much more
powerful than 17 ways to declutter your
closet and that's what we really hope to
provide with the minimalist private
podcast big thanks to Our Guest today Dr
Courtney Warren for joining us you can
check out her new book it's called
letting go of your ex we'll put a link
to that in the show notes and if you
leave here today with just one message
let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign
foreign
every little